victory lap was uh
obviously classic um
and and the attention to detail that you
just spoke about
that's why i always appreciated nip i
feel like everything he did had
intention and it was always on purpose
it was like
he understands what it means to have a
debut rap album yeah
and like how important that is to
deliver on because he's a hip-hop head
too you know
so the process of ua like helping with a
r and that album walk us through that
because there was like
some records on there that were just so
like
you know like hearing belly on double up
you know what i mean like like
like like what did you bring to the
process because nip
obviously had his his the way he made
records but i feel like there were some
records on victory lap that were just so
like
yeah elevated from anything we'd ever
heard from him before
so it was dope about the whole situation
you know mike and keys
um 1500 man they were like the the
producers that kind of laid out the
foundation for the project
um and i remember one day like
i brought him hustling motivate you know
and i remember just being there and his
eyes lightened up
like when i played on the beat for the
first time and like
we talked about him being in the 6-4 in
times square with hove in the passenger
seat like just talking like
it was just like before he recorded that
song it was like that was like our first
record we did together
wow you know what i'm saying so you know
it was just like little thing but more
so it was just like beats like you know
nipsey liked to just have beasts that he
[ __ ] with and he respected just my
opinion
on verses and um structures the songs
and things like that but
you know that [ __ ] was pretty much all
put together
with nipsey's vision were there any um
records
cause you hear rumors and stuff but were
there any uh features that were supposed
to happen or or
that that didn't end up happening for on
victory lap no not really i mean i think
the biggest thing
was important to him was the kendrick
feature right yeah
and and that was cool i mean jay-z of
course everybody
wants that but you know with jay-z
everything happens for a reason
of course he got the song with jay-z now
that's amazing of course
puffy getting puff puff daddy to talk
[ __ ] was that something that was uh
was that like a hard thing to get him in
there no so what happened was the album
was done
yeah and he wants to go play it for puff
and i think puff was just so inspired
when he heard the project that he had to
put his fingers on it you know
saying in his ear and his touch on it
and you know
nipsey is a big you know uh you know
plus one of the people he really look up
to in the music business so of course
you know if you have puff wanting to
work with you and you know add certain
elements to the project
you're gonna let him jump in and do that
so you know i think it was just
inspiration based um
is there a lot of like is there
because we had j stone up here and he
said that there's obviously a lot of
unreleased nipsey music out there
or not out there but you know stuff that
he recorded
is there going to be any sort of
album you know we we've gotten a pop
smoke album we've
i mean tupac passed and we got a i mean
[ __ ] we know how many albums he
put out after he died but is there any
any discussions of
even exploring that i mean you know
everybody knows
how big of a perfectionist nipsey was
and
you know from me i i wouldn't be
comfortable
being involved with putting out no more
nipsey music in the future because
he's not there he's not there to approve
it and i don't want to stand on this
thinking that i'm powerful enough to say
no that's what he would have wanted
so if black sam or somebody his family
or you know somebody
that you know that i feel like could
make that call wants to do it of course
i would help out but
i would never want like i think he left
the legacy that's so crazy in that last
project i just wouldn't want to cloud it
that's fair you know was because because
um racks in the middle
was a record that kind of came out as
like a lucy was that supposed to
be the first single for the next prize
of the next project right yeah yeah
we're about to start doing more features
and like
damn man yeah cause i remember when he
dropped the record he came up to the
station and
and i was like yo so is this the
sinkhole he's like it's just a song for
now you know like we're gonna
yeah damn i mean especially with the
success they had you already know that
with a catapult into
and we had yeah some [ __ ]